foreign
[Music]
well hello guys and welcome to another
episode of the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel it is a gorgeous fall day here
in the dolly sod Wilderness and I've got
what's arguably the lightest backpack in
the world and some of the lightest
backpacking gear that money could buy
but right now it's about 65 degrees
Fahrenheit but it's going to drop down
to 22 degrees Fahrenheit tonight it's
going to be proper cold weather camping
I got into ultralight camping gear and
backpacking gear because I like to take
my kids with me and if you're going to
be carrying gear for two people or three
people or four people it needs to be
light it needs to be small or you'll
never get very far
you can see where the beaver's been
pushing mud up to form a little dike you
can tell this is an active Beaver Pond
because the mud is fresh now you really
don't want to mess with beavers they're
nasty little creatures I once had a
fight one in front of a trooper Boy
Scouts while on a date with my wife
vomited all over our stuff and we had to
get rabies shots
foreign
this Trail has turned to muck which is a
good time to talk about shoes I prefer
to have Trail Runners instead of hiking
boots Trail Runners are basically
lightweight running shoes that are meant
for running on Trails they have good
tread lots of cushion ultra light and
they're super comfortable sometimes
they're waterproof sometimes they're not
but honestly I found that waterproof
shoes don't really make much of a
difference
look at that
oh
that's wet
you know this is pretty typical of my
experience the water always gets in the
top so I find it's much more important
to have a shoe that dries out quickly
and is easy on your feet rather than one
that's a little bit taller or a little
bit more waterproof
getting the mud off
if hiking on uneven Trail makes this
part of your ankle and this part of your
ankle really sore and fatigued then you
probably want more ankle support however
if your hiking shoes are making the
front of your ankle and your shin really
really tired that means your boots are
too heavy and they're wearing you out
I'm the type of person that doesn't have
a problem with rolling my ankle but
lifting my foot up with a heavy boot
makes the front of my foot really tired
so having a light Trail Runner is a big
plus for me
foreign
little mouse ran across my trail
this time of year in the Arctic the
native alaskans will be gathering Mouse
food you go out into the tundra that
looks kind of like this you take a stick
and you probe the ground looking for
mice dens and you find their winter
storage of grains and seeds and you dig
it up and you take it get a little
handful of seeds that look a little bit
like granola but it's a great way to
find food sources that are too tedious
to gather yourself
when it comes to backpacks I'm really in
love with the zpax backpack it's made
from dyneema which is stronger than
nylon completely waterproof and very
light if you're gonna buy a nice
backpack get a waterproof backpack
there's no reason not to
well where'd the trail go
yeah it didn't quite make that jump
oh
here's the trail an extreme ultralight
backpack like this is not the first
piece of ultralight equipment you should
buy most these backpacks are not
designed to carry more than 30 or 40
pounds and if you try to do it you risk
tearing the straps and it'll really dig
into your shoulder if you're looking for
a light backpack that's more durable and
they can really take more weight and has
more volume check out the hyper light
backpacks
you know I'm having all this
conversation about lightweight gear but
if you want to lighten your load the
most important thing you can do is
lighten yourself I was getting a little
fluffy and about a year and a half ago I
went on a diet and dropped 65 pounds
didn't do any exercise but just shedding
all that weight did more for my ability
to go hiking and walk far than anything
my gear has done and it didn't cost me a
single dime it's not much fun but it
sure is cheap all right
yeah Trail kind of petered out here
didn't it
I know I've said it before in previous
videos but I love this Garmin inreach
mini not only is it a GPS but allows me
to send and receive text messages via a
satellite Network my wife can track my
progress see where I am and I can send
and receive messages it's great the
battery lasts three days
I think I need to take a little snack
break
the zpax bags is one of the few
ultralight backpacks with the waterproof
exterior pouch I love it
all right I got two of my favorite Trail
snacks here got a bag of pitted dates
and a cookie one large date is 100
calories and just one chocolate cookie
is 420 calories in my right hand here I
have half of my average daily caloric
intake
if you're gonna do any sort of serious
hiking especially with little kids make
sure you snack regularly while you're
hiking I find that if I go more than
about three hours without stopping and
eating something my energy level starts
to really drop off with little kids that
drop is a lot sharper and more sudden
and they're really not good at
regulating their own bodies so you've
got to do it for them when my middle son
was only four years old we did a 20 mile
hike in Hawaii and I just put a 15
minute timer on my phone and every 15
minutes I'd pull out some gummy snacks
and he'd have to eat a couple take a sip
of water and we just did that all day
long if you or anybody else in your
group starts to feel that energy
dropping first thing you got to do food
and water
ah check it out I think that's Fox poop
right there you can tell it's really old
when it gets that white mold on it
well it's been a few hours since that
swampy bit my shoes are already starting
to feel a lot drier I really think it's
just better to have well ventilated
shoes that dry quickly rather than
having waterproof shoes we've only got
about an hour left of sunlight and I
need to find a spot to camp I want
someplace sheltered out of this wind
I'm gonna need a stick for my tent
now let's just find a nice soft level
spot
all right that's pretty flat
as far as I know this is the lightest
tent in the world z packs makes this as
well it's the same company that makes my
backpack it's made out of the same
material too that dyneema
these are the z-packs carbon fiber tent
Stakes
there we go it's a proper one man tent
plenty of room for yourself and your
gear and it weighs less than any other
tent on the market and all you need is
one stick or a tracking pole and then
you're good to go
and the floor in these tents is actually
waterproof and very durable so you don't
need a ground sheet there's a lot of
dynamic tents on the market but this is
one of the only ones that has a fully
enclosed bug mesh so you won't get bit
up by the mosquitoes
this right here is my sleeping pad it's
the Therm-a-Rest Neo air Uber light this
is the lightest sleeping pad on the
market hands down
those Neo air Uber light air mattresses
are incredibly light there's nothing
else like them but you will put holes in
them they are not durable at all I've
either patched or replaced that air
mattress three times in two years
all right this is my sleeping bag it's
the Western mountaineering Apache it's a
15 degree bag
the reason why I chose Western
mountaineering for this bag is it has
the Gore-Tex windstopper shell having a
pillow isn't exactly a necessity but I
sure sleep a lot better with one and
this sea to Summit Eros regular is
actually a really good Comfort item
hardly takes up any space or weight but
it sure is nice man that sun is going
down and it's starting to get cold
this right here is one of the lightest
down jackets on the market Mountain
Hardwear makes it these down jackets are
so light and they make such a difference
in keeping you warm and this right here
is the lightest rain jacket on the
market from Outdoor Research the whole
jacket just stuffs inside its own pocket
now all of these jackets are designed to
be extremely lightweight they're not
going to be very durable jackets as long
as you take care of them they're great
jackets well one thing that takes up a
lot of space and weight in your backpack
is cooking fuel so I invented something
to try to solve that problem check this
out
this right here is a stove it's made
from titanium and this is my latest
prototype and this thing only weighs a
little bit over one ounce 51 grams to be
precise and allow you to cook an entire
meal with a couple sticks it's
absolutely perfect for a place like this
where there's not a lot of firewood
a bunch of dead fern
got a couple little cotton balls soaked
in vaseline as a fire starter
oh Sun's going down and it's getting
cold so I'm going to change into dry
socks and warm pants here
I'm gonna put on my headlamp this one's
made by Nightcore I believe it is the
lightest rechargeable headlamp on the
market but unfortunately I seem to have
forgotten to charge it so I'm gonna use
this one always bring a backup headlamp
nothing like a hot curry to warm you up
time to do the dishes
apparently sells a little cup of herbal
tea
don't put the boiling water in this
nalgen bottle check it for leaks shove
that in our sleeping bag and that'll
keep us extra warm all night long just
make sure it doesn't leak all right I
think it's time to get into bed you guys
it's getting late and I'm tired I'm
gonna hit the sack and I will see you
guys in the morning
[Music]
good morning
it is very cold out I don't want to get
out of my bag the zpax tent is a singled
walled tent so anytime it's warmer
inside than outside you'll get
condensation
forming on the walls wherever your head
is from all the moisture from your
breath it can get your bag wet like you
can see right there my around the edge
all right I gotta get up
check it out you can see where the
condensation froze and turned to ice on
my mat look at that
oh my air mattress has a slow leak in it
as it starts to lose air
bits of your body start to touch the
ground and they get cold
okay I got a problem my boots froze
solid last night they are a block of ice
these are definitely Frozen
I always hate it when I do winter
camping videos that are this cold with
no snow on the ground because look at it
it looks so warm and pretty it's cold
out
I think I've got the ice broken up
enough where I can get my feet into the
booth but I don't want to do it until
I'm ready to hike because when I get my
feet in those icy boots it's gonna get
them Frozen so I want the blood to be
pumping and I want to be hiking when I
do that the last thing I'm going to do
before I break camp
foreign
boiled water under my coat trying to
warm me up a little bit last night as I
was going to sleep I could hear a bunch
of large deer or elk right over here
behind this tree
and one of them was coughing I poked my
head out of the tent to get a better
look out of it and scared them all away
all right time to break him
I love this tent it's so quick and easy
to put up and take down
this titanium cools to the touch almost
immediately
it's not a good sign when your toes are
numb before you put them in your Frozen
shoes
my feet are so cold it's painful really
painful gotta get the blood going to my
feet or we're gonna have problems
all right cool down
Sun hasn't melted the ice yet
if I need to get my core as warm as
possible the reason why your fingers and
toes get numb when you're cold is that
your body is cutting off circulation to
your extremities as a way of trying to
preserve your core temperature
so if you want to warm up your fingers
and toes the best thing to do is to heat
up your core
if your core is warm your body won't
restrict circulation to your extremities
even if they're cold
in case you're wondering no I'm not
going to get frostbite it's just not
cold enough frostbite happens when ice
forms in the water inside the cells of
your body and the ice crystals puncture
the walls of the cell and kill the cells
it has to be significantly below
freezing to get frostbite but prolonged
exposure to this kind of conditions can
give you trench foot
you know guys I can see some water I'm
gonna go refill my water bottle
when it comes to water filtration this
is the best system out there basically
it's just a large water bladder with a
filter and a hose
gravity pulls the water through the
filter and you've got clean water
just go ahead and put the hose inside
your water bottle give it about 30 40
seconds and you've got a liter of clean
water which is really important because
this river is basically a giant beaver
toilet
these gravity-fed filters are the best
way to go hands down they are so much
better than the old hand pumps they work
so much better than life straws or the
filtered squeeze bottles but if you have
to go lighter than this your options are
chemicals or boiling it
all right let's keep going
see these little cotton balls sprouting
everywhere good fire tender
oh the mud's starting to thaw out
now a lot of you might be wondering how
much does this entire pack weigh well I
measured it before coming out here and
with everything it was 16 pounds three
ounces almost five pounds of that is
camera equipment two GoPros a selfie
stick a tripod 15 batteries and a backup
battery and various attachments now the
second biggest weight is water I've got
a liter and a half of water in here and
that way it also includes both of these
jackets and the thermal pants I'm
wearing oh I can start to feel my toes
again oh it feels nice
oh the beaver's been busy here
oh we're back at the Beaver Pond notice
how the beavers cut back all the brush
around the pond they do that so that
they can see Predators coming they're
not very tall and when they're out of
the water they feel vulnerable if you're
a homeowner with Beaver problems take
note of this if you go and you cut down
all the brush along the water that's an
open invitation for beavers because
you've just improved their line of sight
a little bit more about the gear I use
on this trip and some of the gear I
didn't get to bring on this trip
um
[Music]
if you don't want mildew all over your
tent you got to dry it out before you
store it same goes with the sleeping
bags
all right guys just real quick let me
show you some other options for
lightweight gear so this is the one man
tent we used today and this is the one
man E bivvy from MSR it's just a little
nylon tube and your sleeping bag and
your mat fit inside and allows you just
to have a little bit of protection no
good in really extreme weather but it's
a fraction of the cost of a lightweight
tent and a fraction of the size and the
weight another option is to get a dyneem
a tarp they're about a third of the
weight of a nylon tarp but when you
compare it to a dyneema tent you only
save a little bit of money and a little
bit of weight so at the end I usually
just go for my tent
so let me give you another comparison
this is the one-man zpax tent we use
today this is the two-man version even
though the two-man tent is more than
twice the volume of the one man tent
it's not twice the weight Additionally
the two-man tent comes with optional
tent poles that you can buy as an add-on
in case you want to use temp holes
instead of two sticks so honestly I end
up using the two-man version even when
I'm by myself more often than not just
because it's a lot more comfortable for
just a little bit extra weight all right
let's talk sleeping bags so this right
here is a generic 20 degree bag it's
filled with a synthetic insulation it's
pretty big it's pretty bulky but it
works well this right here is the bag I
use today it's a 15 degree bag it's
filled with goose down and it's made by
Western mountaineering it's less than
half the volume of the synthetic bag
this right here is a 20 degree sleeping
quilt from Enlightened Equipment because
sleeping quilts are so much more
efficient you can see that they're just
much smaller and much lighter but if you
want to see something really crazy this
right here is the smallest lightest
sleeping bag in the world it's a 60
degree mummy bag made by a company
called Yeti that's from Europe I think
it's from Germany
this is actually the extra long model
and it is a really slim cut it's like
wearing full body skinny jeans but they
don't sell this in the United States I
had to import this thing from Europe all
right guys these are my shoes this is
the pair I was wearing today and they're
all right I like them well enough but I
love these These are the ultra lone
Peaks and these are the lightest shoes
I've ever felt but yet still have really
good support and cushioning but if it's
cold I tend to use these insulated
murals they're really comfortable and
they're warm they're great when it's a
little bit below freezing but if it's
really cold these Solomons are amazing I
absolutely love these for a negative 20
winter boot they are light and
comfortable and a really great boot so
this right here was the air mattress
that I was using today and this right
here is the next lightest alternative
but this seed is Summit ether light XT
is one of my favorite air mattresses on
the market it's so comfortable and very
very reliable honestly I wouldn't use
this one unless you absolutely have to
because of the weight limits whenever I
can I use this one all right here three
bags from three different companies and
I really like these three bags this is
the one we were using today and this
right here is another dyneema bag from a
company called Hyperlite and you can see
it's much bigger it's also much much
more durable but the z-packs bag
actually has a frame and this one does
not and this one only has the mesh
outside pocket well the zpax bag has the
waterproof outside pocket over here this
is a bag from a company called gossamer
gear and it is insanely light it weighs
less than a Daydream it's just insane
but it is not waterproof this is just a
fancy nylon material so it will soak
through and that is a huge downside both
of these bags are waterproof dry bags
individually these are all great
products but relatively they have a
massive effect on what you have to carry
on your back let me give you an example
over here I got a basic backpack like
you get at REI I've got a self-inflating
mat also from REI a 20 degree a
synthetic bag and a one-man tent from
Alps over here I got the z-packs
backpack the zpax one man tent the 20
degree quilt from lighting equipment and
I've got the therm-a-res Neo air Uber
light
this sleeping bag barely fits inside
this bag with all my old gear in it
weighs 14 pounds and you can see it's
about 60 percent full the zpax bag four
pounds four ounces the bag's only about
30 percent full but here check this out
I'm gonna go ahead and put the two-man
tent in here another sleeping pad and
another sleeping quilt I now have two
quilts two pads and a two man tent in my
bag and it's only halfway full and it's
only six pounds two ounces if you're
taking little kids backpacking this
stuff is a lifesaver well we've got
guests coming over tonight so I better
clean up the basement but hopefully you
guys have enjoyed this video if you want
to see more tips and tricks for camping
check out our videos and click subscribe
we put out new videos every Saturday
morning and don't forget to check out
our camping and Adventure playlist I'll
put a link in the video description
below thanks for watching guys I'll see
you next Saturday if you like this video
don't forget to check out the outdoor
Boys YouTube channel where we have
hundreds of videos just like this don't
forget to click subscribe so you can see
other great videos every Saturday
morning hit that Bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching
[Music]